combien coûte ta vie jusqu'à sa retraite
un Français moyen va gagner environ 1,18
millions d'euros c'est moins que la
valeur de ton corps 30 millions de
dollars si on additionne la valeur de
tes organes et substances biologiques
comme ton sang avec Internet ton
existence a encore pris de la valeur
grâce aux données des gens sont prêts à
acheter les tiennes à prix d'or mais
sais-tu à combien tu connais le proverbe
si Internet est gratuit c'est que c'est
toi le produit alors on va t'expliquer
tout ce qui peut se vendre sur toi et
les dangers qu'il y a derrière quel est
le prix de vos données personnelles tu
t'en doutes tout dépend de la
confidentialité de l'information tu veux
une liste de profils avec leur âge
prénom et villes ça s'achète en vrac par
pulleter de 10000 pour dépoussière pas
plus d'un demi centime par personne ces
données sont vendues par d’énormes
entreprises les Data brokers qui comme
axiome détiennent les profils de 68% de
la population mondiale le tout classé
selon plus de 3000 critères et score du
voyage souvent tu as un enfant en bas
âge des allergies de salle de bain
chaque donnée à son prix est fait
doucement grimper la barre sur email
please.com tu peux par exemple acheter
l'adresse email d'un propriét de chien
californien ou d'un catholique retraité
pour une vingtaine de centimes ouais
c'est toujours pas la fortune le final
shell time a créé un simulateur pour
estimer le prix de ta propre vie privée
avec plein de critères personnels je
m'attendais à valoir des centaines
d'euros mais non 50 centimes c'est à ce
prix que se vendent mes données les plus
intimes dans les bases de données de
broker même avec un profil de
consommateur compulsif bourré de thunes
difficiles de dépasser les 1 € avec des
chiffres aussi bas comment expliquer que
le marché de la publicité en ligne pèse
pour plus de 375 milliards de dollars
dans le monde 8 milliards rien qu'en
France ça vous donnerait une valeur de
143 euros par an cette question les
gouvernements aimeraient bien avoir la
réponse pour pouvoir taxer les géants de
la tech il faut estimer ce que chaque
utilisateur de chaque pays leur apporte
le problème c'est que stimule le prix
d'un profil individuel comme on l'a fait
ne correspond plus à la façon dont les
données se vendent ni publicitaires
n'achètent plus en vrac mais directement
par lingot des datas agrégés je veux
tous les parisiens de 30-35 ans qui
aiment le tennis le golf et autres
sports de riches et qui ont changé leur
statut marital récemment on va ainsi
pouvoir te proposer les et sites de
rencontres premium avant même que tu en
aies besoin bienvenue dans le monde de
l'analyse prédictive le prix de tes data
va alors plus cher pour notre exemple
les pubs pour des services légaux sur
Google s'achètent 50 euros le clic pour
Facebook ça leur a rapporté l'année
dernière 115 milliards de dollars si on
le divise par le nombre d'utilisateurs
actifs on arrive à 84 euros par mois sur
ta tête pour Google c'est 240 euros ça
commence à chiffrer là si on additionne
toutes les applications et les sites qui
revendent les données personnelles les
estimations disent que ta vie privée
rapporte à Internet plus de 14000 euros
par an et toi qu'est-ce que tu gagnes
là-dedans 0 nada walou voilà pourquoi un
consultant informatique Frédéric
auxagnard a décidé qu'il allait vendre
ses données lui-même pendant un mois il
a enregistré son écran sa webcam la
position de sa souris sa position GPS et
il a tout mis en vente sur Kickstarter
pour le prix de 2 dollars par jour en
seulement un mois il a récolté 2700
dollars si des gens sont prêts à y
mettre ce prix imaginent le profit qu'il
doit Cyril derrière ici on parle de
vente de données légales mais il existe
aussi un énorme marché parallèle sur le
Darknet ton mot de passe Netflix Yvan
pour 3 euros mais ton compte Gmail peut
vite monter à 80 il y a même des packs
informatiques perso plus carte de crédit
à 100 euros le nec plus ultra étant ton
dossier médical jusqu'à 1000 euros s'il
est bien croustillant et oui une carte
de crédit ça se bloque mais ton carnet
de santé tes examens biologiques
contiennent souvent des choses
extrêmement personnelles
usurpation d'identité pour blanchir de
l'argent à ton nom se procurer des
médicaments grâce à tes ordonnances
voire même te faire chanter en dévoilant
ton intimité tout est possible à
condition d'y mettre le prix ce que
Google et Facebook savent de toi et
effrayant vous avez tous déjà vécu ce
moment bizarre vous discutez d'un truc
avec vos amis en soirée vous ouvrez
votre téléphone et bam une pub
exactement sur le sujet dont vous
parliez en 2018 le youtubeur mitchellow
a mis en place un protocole de test il
parle pendant 5 minutes de jouer pour
chien sur un navigateur vierge alors
qu'il n'a pas de chien résultat
pour nous cibler publiquement après tout
quand on dit ok Google ou dis Siri votre
téléphone s'allume tout seul la preuve
en vrai n'ayez pas peur votre téléphone
n'enregistre et ne traite rien si vous
ne dites pas les mots magiques par
contre 0,2 % de ce que vous dites après
ok Google et écouter par un humain ceci
afin d'améliorer la reconnaissance
vocale donc faites attention aux
dinguerie que vous pouvez dire à Siri
quand vous vous sentez seul j'aimerais
te prendre dans mes bras et
te touche comment expliquer alors cette
histoire de jouer pour chien une
première piste c'est que le test se fait
directement sur Youtube et donc ces
paroles sont retranscrites pour générer
automatiquement des sous-titres et donc
des mots clés mais l'explication la plus
plausible et que nous sommes juste
prévisibles un ancien employé de Google
expliqué dans cet article que Google et
Facebook créent pour chaque utilisateur
un double numérique celui-ci est abreuvé
par toutes vos recherches vos achats vos
LIKES et à force il devient comme vous
la personne qui vous ressemble plus au
monde et stockée dans un ordinateur
quelque part dans le monde on peut par
exemple déterminer quand vous êtes tombé
enceinte à partir des achats que vous
faites cherchez des produits plus
naturels augmenter sa consommation en
calcium c'est des signaux pour
l'algorithme à part c'était plein que sa
fille encore au lycée recevait des mails
des magasins Target lui proposant des
produits pour la grossesse le paternel
va donc taper un scandale c'est
dégueulasse d'inciter une fille si jeune
à avoir un bébé sauf que c'était vrai le
magasin était au courant avant même que
le père le sache à partir de cette
information il est possible d'anticiper
la date de naissance et suivre la maman
sur ses besoins à toutes les étapes de
sa vie jusqu'aux études de son enfants
18 ans plus tard ce qui peut donner des
situations tragiques en 2018 une
journaliste américaine a accouché d'un
enfant mort-né ça les pubs ne le
savaient pas encore alors elle continue
d'être spammées de produits pour bébé
jusqu'à ce qu'elle décide de cliquer sur
les cases pas intéressé l'algo a compris
qu'elle n'en avait finalement pas il lui
a donc proposé d'adopter un enfant cruel
tout est analysé recherche Google
position GPS poste like et même vos
conversations privées sur messenger
jusqu'en 2018 Google lisait même vos
mails ça permet de lier les données
entre elles avec un niveau de
personnalisation totalement dingue
prenons l'exemple de ces deux
présentatrices télé lui ne revient d'un
voyage en Airbnb il discute de son
séjour magie une pub Airbnb sur le
téléphone de sa copine est-ce que le
téléphone a eu besoin de les écouter pas
du tout il suffit d'utiliser leur
position GPS elles sont deux copines qui
discutent souvent l'une était à
l'étranger et à louer à Airbnb une
semaine après leur deux téléphones sont
côte à côte preuve qu'elles sont à
nouveau ensemble et qu'elles vont
discuter de quoi d'après vous du voyage
de la première logique dans cet exemple
c'est inoffensif mais j'en ai trois
autres bien plus effrayants on peut
d'abord influencer votre vote grâce aux
informations collectées sur les votants
depuis Facebook le staff de Trump en
2016 a pu analyser ce que leur candidat
devait dire pour faire balancer les
indécis de son côté envoyer des spot sur
la garde d'enfants auprès des mers
actives ou cibler les électeurs noirs
avec une animation d'Hillary Clinton
insultant la communauté deuxième exemple
vous refusez un prêt la société
crédithèque en Allemagne scruter les
réseaux sociaux les achats en ligne et
même les géolocalisations de ses clients
pour déterminer s'il avait un profil à
risque émérité ou non qu'on leur prête
de l'argent la même avec les compagnies
d'assurance qui peuvent scruter votre
opposition GPS en voiture pour savoir si
vous conduisez trop vite si vous prenez
bien les virages et si vous vous garez
dans les endroits sûrs une conduite trop
sportive et le prix de votre assurance
pourrait être revu à la hausse malin
tous ces exemples vous effraient vous
l'avez pourtant accepté de plein gré
dans leurs conditions d'utilisation vous
savez ce truc que personne ne dit
quelqu'un l'a fait pour vous et ça met
plus d'une heure par contre tout a été
résumé ici et quand c'est rouge c'est
que c'est très limite autant vous dire
que c'est la norme mais peut-on vraiment
ne pas partager ces données voulez-vous
faire une idée des données que vous
laissez fuiter c'est justement cette
expérience que vous vous propose notre
partenaire mes data et moi ils vont vous
simuler une journée entière de partage
de données en 10 minutes avec un score à
la fin si vous êtes en retard quelle
application utiliser vous pour prévenir
votre date ou pour faire votre achat en
ligne vous trouverez ainsi une liste de
conseils très précis pour éviter d'être
traqué voilà mon score c'est beaucoup
alors que je pensais faire très
attention à mes traces numériques
dites-nous en commentaire quel score
vous avez eu histoire qu'on compare mais
data et moi c'est un site de la MAIF
vous offrant tout un tas de conseils sur
ses enjeux du futur une façon pour la
MAIF 2 vous protéger non seulement dans
la vraie vie mais aussi sur scène
numérique car les deux sont liés et
c'est cool qu'un assureur en prennent
autant conscience merci à eux d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo alors sans vous
spoiler tous les bons conseils qu'il y a
sur mes data et moi qu'est-ce que vous
pourriez faire pour limiter votre
tracking effacez vos données légalement
vous avez le droit de le demander mais
accrochez-vous c'est le parcours du
combattant pour chaque site envoyer un
courrier par la poste attendre la
réponse les relancer ses réponses pas et
en dernier recours portez plainte bref
la flemme une blogueuse attachia a tenté
l'expérience de vivre sans laisser
aucune trace sans Facebook et même sans
Google échanger Microsoft pour Linux
Messenger pour cya algmail pour proto
mail Google pour duckduck Go il y a des
outils alternatifs pour presque tout GPS
cloud e-commerce c'est juste qu'ils sont
moins pratiques moins interconnectées et
puis dans le cas d'attaque ça ça lui
coûte quand même 400 € par mois avec de
sacrés compétences en gestion de serveur
informatique combien d'entre vous
seraient d'accord pour ce sevrer
d'autant de confort si plutôt que de se
fatiguer à lutter on voyait le positif
utilisez cette quantité stratosphérique
de données pour améliorer notre vie dans
le domaine de la santé par exemple en
Allemagne ils savent prédire l'évolution
de la pandémie de covid-19 uniquement
grâce aux montres connectées quand la
fréquence cardiaque augmente et le
nombre de pas baisse c'est qu'a priori
vous êtes cloué au lit avec de la fièvre
si on prend l'exemple de l'écologie vous
savez que l'agriculture a un gros impact
négatif sur l'environnement baisse de la
biodiversité artificialisation des sols
besoin en eau utilisation des pesticides
là aussi la data va nous aider on peut
optimiser la gestion de l'eau la
température des serres la quantité
d'engrais c'est sûr que la vie privée
des plantes est moins importante que la
vôtre mais c'est bien la preuve que
cette technologie peut aussi sauver des
vies sans compter que sans elle vous ne
regarder pas cette vidéo si elle vous a
été suggéré c'est parce que YouTube sait
que vous êtes intelligent que vous aimez
la science et les technologies si on a
eu des moyens de la faire c'est parce
que vous avez eu une pub ciblée en début
de vidéo cette expérience personnalisée
est gratuite à un prix individuellement
pas grand chose mais collectivement un
marché mondial de plusieurs centaines de
milliards de dollars il nous faudrait
donc pas que la peur de ce qu'on ne
maîtrise pas soi-même mène à une
interdiction 11 discernement ça pourrait
anormantir un des meilleurs leviers que
l'on a pour construire un monde meilleur
et vous qu'en pensez-vous
vous rappelle que cette vidéo est en
partenariat avec le site medataz et moi
de la MAIF qui vous propose une petite
expérience dans le lien en description